we are very proud i love that we get to
do this for you to reveal the 2022
national teacher of the year only on cbs
mornings where this happens this
outstanding educator is chosen by the
non-profit council of chief state school
officers this year's finalists include
colorado's autumn rivera hawaii's
whitney aragaki ohio's kurt russell and
pennsylvania's joseph welch and the 2022
teacher of the year this is my drum roll
none other than
kurt russell hey
he's a history teacher at oberlin high
school and we're glad to tell you that
mr russell's known for emphasizing
cultural relevance and representation
through classes like race gender and
oppression he's joining us as you see at
the table we say welcome and
congratulations to you mr russell thank
you so much all right guys
when we heard the name kurt russell we
went what movies
don't people do that to you all the time
all the time i get that all the time and
so it's just a pleasure to be here with
you this morning glad you're here
pleasure i'm glad you're here before we
get started we've got lots to discuss we
have a little surprise for you mr
russell comes from several of your
students who wanted to pay tribute to
tell us why you're so deserving roll
tape please shantae
good morning
mr russell is such an incredible teacher
and person in general he's really active
when he teaches like very expressive are
you sure
you positive it's like he commands like
your attention he's just really
enthusiastic and he relates his
curriculum to real world experiences
marcus garvey is saying the same thing
you walk in there and it's just lessened
the whole time he wants us to truly
engage with one another and embrace new
ideas
on this side say
yes on this side say no mr russell
always strives for every student to
succeed in this classroom he really
opens your mind the biggest lesson i've
learned from him is to confront the
uncomfortable don't be embarrassed but i
really have to call on someone he does a
really good job of fostering
conversations where
everyone can have a perspective
[Music]
what you see in kurt russell it's real
he's such a dedicated person such a
vital piece in this community good
caring person an amazing role model
write this down practice this is
important i wish like everybody could
take a class with him i just get to have
like a conversation with him because
that's how great he is
kurt we're so very proud of you you're
changing lives you're motivating young
people each and every day
and we are so blessed and proud to have
you
in our district teaching our children
okay
oh now don't you want to go to mr
russell's class i'll go first i don't do
yes
congrats what does it mean to you i mean
we all live to hear praise from
colleagues so what does it mean to hear
that you mean so much to the students
and the people you work with you know
what it's such a blessing to work for
oklahoma city schools um i work for a
tremendous school district and the kids
are so wonderful and i get inspiration
from my students and each and every day
my students bring a sense of
respect a sense of an eagerness to learn
and just fortunate that i'm a part of
this great
part of it no but they say they get
inspiration from you that's right so
where did it come from that you wanted
to be a teacher to begin with
ironically it was three pictures three
pictures three simple pictures one two
three go yes um growing up in the south
when my family grew up in the south and
they also had these three pictures
martin luther king jr jfk and jesus and
i was so interested in those three
pictures and became interested in
stories and that's history it's just
nothing but stories and i just really
fell in love with the aspiration of
telling stories
wow um you heard from mr larry thomas
there who's your mentor i love this idea
because we've all talked about this how
every one of us can name teachers that
have impacted us
in our lives i mean i can go back to
kindergarten and name every year a
teacher who inspired me and to have mr
thomas talk about you in the way that he
did you're standing on his shoulders how
does that feel well mr thomas was the
first black male teacher i ever had wow
and since my kindergarten days i always
wanted to be a teacher so mr thomas
showed me the attainable goal of being a
teacher gave me that inspiration the way
he dressed the way he just carried
himself and it means a lot for me to
hear mr thomas speak highly of me you
mentioned stories and being able to
communicate those stories
it's tough for teachers to take history
and then communicate it to a young mind
in a way that
creates an engagement and you do that
listening to your students um but you
take that head on though you teach
african-american history and you also
have a course uh that gail mentioned
race gender and oppression yes now race
is a big debate in this country why do
you take it head-on
because it's my responsibility to
provide my students with a holistic
opportunity to learn
um the one thing that i really would
like to stress
receiving this award is to make sure
that students receive a well-rounded
diverse education okay and that starts
with faculty and staff
and also starts within the curriculum as
well making sure that students see
themselves in the curriculum and i
believe that's how students are engaged
a hot topic is critical race theory it's
very hard to get your thoughts on that
and why do you believe it's such a hot
topic in this country well first of all
i do not teach critical race theory
what i teach is history i try to make
sure that my students have the most
opportunity to learn and the way i do
that is through engagement by allowing
my students to see themselves in the
curriculum and by seeing themselves in
the curriculum students are growing um
from my own experience with my students
in my classroom i see that
my courses are electives and so it's not
a mandatory course and students are
signing up wow that means they want to
be there i love when one student said
you command respect you command
attention you're very engaging what was
it like for you teaching during the
pandemic because you couldn't be with
your kids face to face it was really
difficult
yes it was it was difficult for not only
teacher but other professions as well
because i was not engaged with my
students zoom you mean with zoom that
computer screen that barrier uh was very
difficult for me i like being in the
classroom with my students being
engaging and i get feedback i get energy
from my students as well so it was
difficult rumor is you're going to be
invited to the white house whoa
whoa
we haven't been invited to the white
house yet so what's your what's your
message and dr jill biden you know is a
teacher she's one of your homies so she
understands this yeah my message is
clear to provide a diverse education
opportunity for all students and when i
mean diverse
representing faculty and staff as well
only two percent of teachers are black
males but it's more than that only two
percent wow then there's more than that
it's women in stem it's men in the
primary years um and also to provide my
students with a diverse curriculum to
make sure the african-american history
class and race gender and depression
class become normalized and not
different well we appreciate you thank
you so much and congratulations yes
congratulations thank you for
approaching your job with passion thank
you not all teachers do we appreciate
you you guys are the true superheroes
kurt russell the real kurt russell by
the way
i'm